you
[Music]
please welcome director data science
Microsoft Research Vani man Dava hello
everyone and welcome to these last two
sessions of faculty summit 2018 so in
2017 57% of professional occupations in
the United States were held by women yet
only 17% of Fortune 500 CIOs positions
were held by women in computing
specifically only 26% of jobs were held
by women the numbers are even lower for
underrepresented groups black and
Hispanic men for example hold only 9% of
computing jobs and the numbers for black
and Hispanic women are an abysmal 4
percent as a result the technical
products and services that we use today
have been created by a single large
homogenous group of people men
considering the impact that technology
has on our economy our society and our
lives it makes sense to pause and
consider the question what is women and
other groups underrepresented in
technology were at the table designing
and creating technology alongside men
this panel of computing innovators will
explore the exciting outcomes that are
possible if diverse perspectives were
brought to the table it is my pleasure
to introduce Lucy Sanders our esteemed
moderator for this distinguished panel
lucy sanders a CEO and co-founder of the
National Center for Women and
information technology and C wit Lucy
has extensive industry background having
worked in R&D in executive vp positions
at AT&T Labs Bell Labs and Avaya Labs
for over 20 years
lucy specialized in systems-level
software and solutions and also holds
six patents in the area of
communications technology lucy is the
recipient of the very prestigious Bell
Labs fellow award which is the highest
technical accomplishment bestowed at the
company Luci currently serves as a
trustee for the Colorado School of Mines
the Center for American entrepreneurship
in Washington DC and the international
computer science Institute at the
University of California Berkeley she
has served on the information technology
research and development ecosystem
Commission for the National Academies
and the innovation advisory board for
the US Department of Commerce on behalf
of Microsoft it is a great honor to
welcome Lucy Sanders and our
distinguished and our distinguished
panel for this session
[Applause]
well thanks Barney for that really great
welcome and welcome to Jim and Margaret
and a Bellotti for coming today and
sharing some insights around diversity
and innovation as a community those of
us in computing and all of us are I
think in this room we talk about
broadening participation in computing
quite a bit when we get together and
often we'll talk about it as a pipeline
issue we need to focus on the computing
educational pipeline and that's true
we do that's a very important thing or
we'll talk about it as being the right
thing to do well paying jobs for a
diverse group of people a workforce
issue and those are all true as well but
today we're not going to talk about any
of those important things we're going to
talk today about the link between
innovation and diversity it's often a
conversation we don't stop and have and
when you think about it it's the real
reason why we're in this game it's not
just a numbers game we want to see what
great creative ideas would come to the
table when diverse populations are there
so the link between innovation and
diversity between creativity and
diversity between great research
outcomes and diversity all really
important things that this panel will
explore everybody on the panel today is
a noted innovator and his or her own
right and also somebody who cares deeply
about diversity and inclusion or my
favorite new word belonging you know
where you where you are working and
where you are studying so it's a super
important topic because we know from
research and bonnie mentioned some of
this in her opening remarks that diverse
teams solve complex problems faster and
they get to a better answer
they are also have they have higher
collective intelligence in
problem-solving as well it's very
important that these diverse teams be
very well managed
because homogeneous teams are often
easier to manage but they don't
necessarily get to the most innovative
outcome so it's important that they be
really well managed as well so I know
these are things we all care about
and our panelists care about it too so
we're going to start the question with a
little bit of storytelling here because
I think it's important to establish this
link from their broad perspective this
as innovators about the links they've
seen between technical innovation and
diversity so I'm going to ask each one
we'll go will go first to Margaret
Thank You Margaret to talk about a
technical project or team they were
involved in that had particularly
innovative results so the link between
innovation and diversity so Margaret
tell us about your story we're going to
geek out so we're gonna really be
talking about technology and really geek
out here so go ahead Margaret sure
thanks so it's wonderful to be here I
guess I rather than think about sort of
one zoomed in I'm going to talk about
sort of an overall culture that's been a
my my research group over the twenty
five years now nearly that I've been at
Princeton and that is about projects
that are interdisciplinary so there's a
diversity of topic a diversity of skill
sets that come in and then a diversity
of backgrounds and genders and so forth
as well so about a little over 15 years
ago I started a project called zebra net
that was basically started because I a
computer systems person who cared about
power efficiency got coupled with one of
my biology colleagues from across campus
who wanted better wildlife tracking
devices and we worked across that
intellectual gap to come up with designs
that sort of abided by their needs and
their desires to get better fine grained
tracking of zebras and abided by I'm
sort of the engineering constraints to
the problem which was very tough power
constraints and GPS limitations and so
forth coupled in all of that was a
diversity of people as well because you
bring in people with conservation
experience you bring in people with deep
engineering experience male/female
different parts of the stack and I think
it was a very fertile place to have
group meetings because you'd have to
explain things carefully across those
lines which makes you a better
communicator but you also come up with
interesting
research ideas that lie in the inner
sis's between different topic areas I
think it's the first time I've heard
diversity being different parts of the
stack it's pretty fun Morgan well Jim
what about to you tell us your story
okay well before I say its story let me
let me I have to set the stage for the
story all right I think something that
we're seeing in computing now is sort of
a move from computing being tools to
computing being partners with people at
the National Science Foundation where
I'm working right now we talked about
the human technology frontier and we
talked about technology that really
means computing maybe we shouldn't say
that tall everybody across the National
Science Foundation but that's sighs
that's what we think about and when we
think about you know the human
technology frontier it's all of humanity
so in a sense I take it to be really
axiomatic that if we're building tools
that we're going to partner with as
humans that it's got to be for all of
humanity so it's axiomatic that we're
going to that we want to embrace and
engage across all different aspects of
diversity whether it be cultural
socio-economic gender however you
measure it so my story my favorite
project I worked on actually it was all
the way up and down the stack also when
at the University of Massachusetts we
had a project on collaborative adaptive
sensing of the atmosphere it was about
the system concept was this dense
network of low powered radars that would
sense hazardous weather and predict and
into early-warning and detection of
hazardous weather and the do morning out
to folks and to me that's sort of a
quintessential socio technical smack at
the dab smack dab at the human
technology frontier and it was diverse
so yes it went all the way up and down
the stack all the way from designing
waveforms to deciding when to issue
warnings to people it was all so diverse
in in the the backgrounds of people who
were there we had meteorologists we had
computer scientists that was me in terms
of the leadership meteorologists
computer scientists atmospheric
scientists sociologists electrical
engineers all working side by side we
had let's see an Asian American that was
indian-american we had a Latino and
african-american and two white males in
our in our leadership team and so I
think we just had incredible diversity
in that and I think of all of the
projects that that I've worked on to me
that was the most rewarding because of
all of the diverse viewpoints we had to
bring to solve that end-to-end system
all the way from the designing radar
forms all the way up to doing
notifications so interdisciplinary also
seems to be coming out in this
conversation as well so habla do you how
tell us your story
I also have an interdisciplinary story
and so we see I think you know the
things that you share the gym you know
and Maya really resonated the project
that I'm thinking about is project Rome
which was an effort that we started to
really rethink you know how you interact
you know with your computer in a world
where you don't just have one where you
have several you know you're doing
things on your mobile device
you're doing things you know maybe on a
laptop maybe you have a workstation
where you do other things and as we got
started on this project one of the first
things that we did is we assembled a
team of folks from marketing folks from
user experience design
you know folks like me who are plumbers
who understand the operating system and
communications and we started by trying
to tell the story and what we found was
that by start by trying to tell the
story first that multidisciplinary
approach you know we we picked the
problems that we wanted to solve you
know in a much better way you know and
we were able to focus some of you may
have seen you know like we launched a
feature recently called your phone that
lets you link your phone and PC and use
them seamlessly get messages on your PC
you know see photos you know in your PC
from your phone you know that in a lot
of ways is a culmination of a journey
that started you know from taking a
slightly different approach
traditionally in the operating system we
would start with the technology and then
we would go looking for the problem and
in this in this in this in this case I
think it was it was eye-opening you know
how much of a difference it made and the
final result
you know just assembling a different set
of perspectives at an early phase you
know in going after a problem excuse me
so so it's so interesting I've loved
operating systems too I'd rather just do
operating systems let the problems find
me you know more fun just a joke anyway
so so when I was at Bell Labs in the
early 90s I did a project it was a
multimedia communications server
enterprise it's a mash-up between Skype
and Google Docs you know in 1993 and the
team was hugely diverse you know racial
racial diversity gender diversity all
kinds of ethnicities on this team and it
was really that project that kind of got
me thinking about a little bit of a slow
learner like wait a minute wow this is
awesome all these different kinds of
people
well apps had great diversity you know
and a lot of that came because we hired
really smart thinkers mathematicians
scientists and they learned how to
create hardware and software yes so it
was very diverse it was a really
interesting project and unfortunately
not all teams are this way we know from
from our stats and I'm gonna give you a
few stats just to kind of put a little
foundational grounding under this that
I'm gonna give you some stats that are
about gender but I also want to
reinforce again we need stats on all
groups participation there are a number
of historically marginalized groups in
computing in this particular case and
these case studies I'm about ready to
tell you it the process we could really
only look at gender but their innovation
metrics different than participation
metrics which makes them different than
the ones we normally look at so this is
really around you know more meaningful
participation in computing so and see
what runs a patenting study we update it
every couple years we crowd the US
Patent database with gender matching
software and we assign a gender to every
every inventor on every IT patent and
then we look at the results and IT is
the government's definition of IT so
it's all things computing it's
everything in the computing community
and end result over the last 30 years
88% of all patents have male only
invention teams or that's one or more
men 2% have female only invention teams
and the rest are mixed so so of course
patenting is only one innovation metric
so we did the same thing on the ACM
paper database for papers accepted to
ACM conferences and we did the same type
of thing the end of over 600,000 it was
a pretty big end and about 78% of all
authors on accepted papers to to ACM
about 78% are male and and the rest are
female 22 % now that numbers not you'd
like it to be higher let's just face it
right but it's not so bad when you
consider women's participation is
computing faculty in major in research
institutions it tracks about what you
would expect but the real thing in this
particular study was the substation of
papers between women and men women were
mostly in in documentation
human-computer interface not systems not
networking not algorithms so huge
substation real quickly just to let you
know overall participation numbers women
make up about 13 percent of all hardware
developers and about 18% of all software
developers so I think it's pretty safe
to say with numbers like these and
others that we're missing out on a large
set of creative ideas from over half the
population when it comes to innovation
and research in the areas we care about
so that's like a huge untapped potential
that if we could just figure out what to
do here there's an innovation gap and a
huge upside potential if we solve it so
my second question is going to be if I
get to it here we go the as panelist and
as in you know as innovators yourself
you know what do you think why do you
think it's critical to close this
innovation gap you've hinted at some of
that in the answers to your first
questions why do you think it's critical
to close this and why do you think we
have this why do you think it's
happening
I'm going for style bloody all right
yeah the word that comes to mind to me
when I think about the importance of
diversity in innovation is robustness if
you think about an idea sort of as a
living thing you know like it's
survivability you know depends heavily
you know on its composition at birth and
ideas that come out of diverse teams
ideas that reflect at birth you know a
set of diverse perspectives not just you
know that a coders perspective on what
algorithm he can write you know but say
a marketing person's perspective on what
what things matter you know to end-users
you know a human-computer interaction
specialist you know perspective you know
on on what is usable you know a man's
perspective you know a woman's
perspective and Africans perspective you
know various backgrounds you know when
all of those are present you know at the
birth of an idea
it's the likelihood that it will not die
on the way to adulthood is much higher
you know and I think that metaphor is is
helpful because really I think what we
care about not just as innovation but
innovation that has impact and
innovation that has impact you know has
the characteristic to me at least you
know that that there are things that
have been thought through and
incorporated at every stage along the
way that really can only get in there
that can only really be woven in you
know if you have a set of diverse
perspectives that reflects the world in
which that idea is going to actually
exist there was another question I know
it was a double-barreled question which
is really unfair so the the second part
of the question was why do you think we
have this gap why do I think it's
familiarity I think that the the easiest
thing to do is what you tend to see the
most stuff and I think it takes real
effort you know to apply a
multidisciplinary approach I think it
takes real effort to number one identify
a lack of diversity and then number two
correct it you have to be intentional
about it and I think that without the
right mindset you know
without the right framework you know
around optimizing for you know diversity
in our approach I think the default
behaviors tend to dominate I might
answer the second question first by how
did we get here I think it ties back to
this this notion of the human technology
frontier and a shift from computing
focusing more on computing in databases
and operating system network says
artifacts and more now towards computing
partnering with humans and more on the
application side and I think we were
able to maybe slide by without the
diversity as much diversity before
because it was more looking at artifacts
now if we're building we're building
technologies that are going to partner
with humans there's just absolutely no
way we can get by without that
university of perspectives I think
that's a really good point Margit what
do you think I wanted to zoom in on a
particular part of the timeline which is
sort of the time from late in a PhD
onwards into one's career and I want to
zoom in in particular on the systems
research community writ large and I want
to say that it is really easy to think
about the numbers that we have in our
undergrad programs which thankfully are
coming back up again actually first
thing is concrete example I represent
the peak year in terms of percentage
production of women CS bachelor's
degrees in America I'm 53 years old the
peak was 1986 we came back down for many
many years and now we're coming back up
so so first of all there's this notion
that the pipeline will save us where the
pipeline was draining and the second of
all the other part of it is that PhD
production has hung in there at around
15 to 20 percent women for many years
because we refill internationally even
though our us numbers undergrad have
fluctuated so you look in that later
part of the career and you say we could
have been sort of sustaining about 20
percent participation in our systems
research community but if you look at
the ACM Sigma Mercia precedes the we
represent in
this room sig ops sigplan and sigcomm
have less than 5% women membership sig
Ark comes in that's my sig at around 8%
and kudos to sig Mobile which tops out
just above 10% so something's happening
in how we're cultivating the second part
of a person's career like we get them to
the point of getting a PhD but do we
cultivate what sustains them longer term
than that that's not as clear to me that
we are doing as much in the way of long
term mentoring and long term
appreciation and and I think a first
step is as systems researchers we
measure what we care about so we should
be measuring more of this data in an
ongoing way we should get a friend or
represented groups so that we can see at
a conference how many of the first
authors presenting the paper were women
or underrepresented minorities it's
often very small and and it's very hard
to know so I think better data tracking
used to motivate better mentorship and
sustained career development would be
great and you're touching some on
culture so we again to really not focus
on the educational pipeline but what
happens after I can I can say a bit
about the workforce you know the
corporate workforce oh one of the
biggest things that we hear there
unhospitable culture when you start to
really you know sort of dig into that
you find out that for example women tend
to be more in the support roles that
support the creative endeavors of an you
know innovators so they would be in
project management system verification
customer requirements very important
things by the way don't get me wrong
super important but they're not the
things that would lead generally to a
promotion up the technical ladder so so
what happens then you'll like to be a
CTO or an architect or a distinguished
engineer and they just don't lead there
generally speaking so by mid-career they
get sort of frustrated and they leave
you know so so they're not even at the
stage of their career yet where they
could be innovators they don't have the
task assignments okay so when you drill
down into that a lot of supervisors
technicals
supervisors really have no idea how they
are signed rolls tasks assignments etc
so those are the kinds of things we have
to really start being curious about and
all the people in this room are
analytical you all have a great spirit
of inquiry if we start really getting
your data and digging into it and being
curious about it as market is saying and
look for some of the ways we can take
bias out of some of these systems I
think the gap will will close but we
have to really be curious and analytical
about it just in the same way you are
around cloud computing or you know
anything else so that's what we've seen
in workforce and I suspect it's it's
somewhat true in academia as well would
anybody want to comment on what the
culture is like for young researchers
and or old researchers who are your new
PhDs in academia so I'm a lifelong
unapologetic academic I I love it I
think it's the best job in the world and
frankly I think we do an okay job in
many ways of cultivating our young
faculty members I would x worried that
we don't explicitly say how much fun
we're having
I try to explicitly say how much fun I'm
having because I think people need to
see that you you want to engage in a
path that a shows impact and B looks
enjoyable and so I try to model that
more explicitly myself and I think in
academia there are flexibilities to the
way you operate groups and the way you
so manage your time that are incredibly
compelling and getting the word out
about that is super important super
important so Tim what is NSF doing in
this space you're well known for a brand
new participate let me answer the NSF
question but I will say that like
Margaret I'm a lifelong academic and
absolutely loved it and and many of the
challenges that I think we face with
diversity in computing are faced across
really across the university and that my
sense is that universities are becoming
more attuned to that and more flexible
in hiring and tenure processes and so I
see some light at the end of the tunnel
there let me put on my NSF hat and say a
couple words about NSF so there's a long
history well ten years I suppose it's
not that long
but certainly a recent and really
storied history of activities here in
broadening participation in computing
there the BPC alliances like nCWIT like
CRA w access computing kashi and others
and these have been ongoing activities
for ten years that that I just think
I've been absolutely fabulous there are
mentoring programs so Margaret mented
mentioned the importance of mentoring at
the undergraduate level career mentoring
grad women's cohort so projects and
activities like that we're not talking
much about the pipeline but I can't help
but mention computer science for all and
we like to really say for all to
emphasize the equity and the access to a
rigorous and really compelling computer
science education in cake through twelve
and that's an activity that make we're
really really proud of one of the things
that's happened there in addition to the
ECS computing that folks may have heard
about the computer science principles
the second AP exam was offered the first
time in 2017 50,000 students took it
between what 2017 and 2016 the number of
students taking the AP exam either of
the AP exams in computer science more
than double the number of women more
than double the number of Hispanic
students more than double the number of
african-american students so I think
that speaks really well for the pipeline
I will tell you since many of you are
academics here that challenge is going
to be when those students show up on our
academic doorsteps are we going to have
programs that that welcome them and the
kinds of computing that that they want
to do I see that as a as a challenge you
know I think one of the as wonderful as
those are you know it's sometimes it's
too easy to sit here and say oh look at
all those great things that are going on
but Lucy Sanders of the world will take
care of B PC for us right and and and
they do wonderful things but it's a
challenge for all of us I think and you
know looking out here really all of us
here have a responsibility and a need to
address that and and so a new program
actually that we're we're sort of
piloting at the National Science
Foundation
I know many people here don't read the
Dear Colleague letters that I write but
you should read Dear Colleague letter 17
1:10 meaningful engaging in meaningful
broadening participation activities and
what we're trying to do here is to make
this what we NSF are trying to do here
we've piloted this in the very large
grants we're going to pilot it next year
in some of the select mediums and in
large grants the idea here is that
everybody who's funded under an NSF
grant should take part in some kind of
meaningful BPC activity it doesn't mean
you have to go out and start the next MC
wint or or CRA W but there's something
that every one of us can do to help
broaden participation and convene many
of the ones that Margaret just mentioned
for example and so you know we're really
very excited about that and so if I
could leave you with one thought I've
been a teacher for 32 years I guess you
know if you walk away with one thing
here's one thing to walk away read Dear
Colleague letter 17 110 or send me an
email and all I'll send it to you that's
great what's number again 17 110 okay so
if we had rehearsed this we'd have
November show up announcements tab of
the Microsoft you know research to
faculty and faculty research site that'd
be great
I want to just throw in sort of a one
question before I ask the final question
cuz I don't want to leave the panel
without maybe asking for a few
observations on what the researchers
will call intersectionality the the
notion that we all identify in different
ways and multiple ways you know that in
fact you know I could be a white woman
from the south or you know I could be I
could be a black man from New York City
or you know all kinds of different
intersecting identities and so we don't
want to leave you with the notion that
there's you know like a shopping list of
things you can do a proffer abroad new
participation and have to be very
thoughtfully done so anybody I didn't
you know any thoughts on this or I think
it's a super important topic to just
make sure people know that word
intersectionality and how we can't just
assume all women are the same
blacks are the same or a Latinas are the
same so III guess I would again stress
that as Lucy just said it shouldn't be a
checklist that you should find something
that you want to do and and actually
engaging in existing structures and what
people will call scaffolding so maybe
there is you know a CSTA that you
working and engage with there may be
your department or your college is doing
something that you can engage in and
it's not like you have to go out and oh
do a checklist oh I better go do X find
something that's meaningful for you that
you can relate to because that's the
kind of contribution that will make a
difference to people or on the receiving
end of that contribution any thoughts on
that one I guess I would add you know
when I'm running a research group one of
the things I try to be aware of is
having enough diversity along many
dimensions that everybody in the end can
just be themselves it doesn't feel like
a dominant group and a outsider
department and in the process you end up
with you know a weight lifter who
happens to be female and a kind of quiet
Harry Potter male and you know sort of
everything everyone's allowed to be
individuals because there isn't sort of
a dominant culture and recessive or
Outsiders feeling again returning to the
word belonging and I think that's
everybody wants to belong and contribute
and do the best work of their lives so
it's super important so let's do one
last question to each panelist with
starting for Bellotti
one idea Jim already gave us his so you
get another one are you not repeat the
same on if you really if you really want
to emphasize that one idea that you can
take out of this room today and do
immediately that doesn't cost much money
for broadening participation as it
relates to innovation and diversity
again I think you know you really want
to come back and and hit that you know
that where we have the biggest gap in
many ways the pipelines is some sense
filling right we're starting to see
where these students arrive we want them
then in their research careers or in
their corporate careers to be able to
innovate and to create
and to bring their best life experiences
to the table and do really great
technology works so what would be one
thing that you could leave people with
that they could do can I say two things
yes just like Jim you want to be just
like Jim okay all right so the two
things for me really are be an advocate
and set an example we have an internal
conference here at Microsoft called
whips you know it's by invitation only
it's our top technical conference and I
remember their few years ago
Galen Hunt whom 70 of you you may know
stood up at whips you know during the
session for poster talks and he said
look around the room you know everyone
look around the room and he said there
are very many women here and I think
that's a problem and so what I would
like you to do you know is the next time
you want to invite me to whips take my
invitation
you know and give it to a woman one of
our Women Engineers instead and he sat
down and I thought that was really great
I think that it's a it's it's all of us
have the ability to affect decisions
that are made you know daily in our
context in a positive direction and it's
a tool that is relatively cheap for us
to exercise and so that's the first
thing that I would leave folks with is
you know look at you know like
conference selection
you know settings you know paper
selection and and just be an advocate
the second one is set an example and
what I mean by that is that when you're
assembling a team along the lines that
Margaret you know mentioned be
intentional you know about looking you
know at the set of people that you have
around you and asking mid-14th Isis are
there people whom I'm not even
considering you know is the set of
perspectives that I have actually
diverse and and the reason to do that
you know is because the statistics that
we're looking at they don't come out of
a vacuum they actually come out of the
set of people you know who are in this
room writ large and the way in which
those statistics change you know is that
all of us you know exercise back
pressure against our default tendency
that's absolutely right absolutely right
I guess I have to do - now - when the
pressures on like to keep up again right
so one that's super cheap and it just
requires you to remember is I think we
lose track of how much students and
people junior to us responds to even
modest tiny bits of feedback and so the
quick email at the end of the class or
after a midterm that says you would be
great if you continued on in this field
you would be great if you considered
grad school it's a 10 word email and it
will make a difference in someone's life
often even if they don't do what you
think they'd be great at they heard it I
guarantee that's one the second thing is
that by virtue of who we are we are
fairly senior and so we're more often in
the position of being allies to things
that are going on then are sort of being
in the sort of picked on situations
ourselves these days and so I would
encourage you to sort of look at the
world with your ally hat on and remember
to say things like I didn't find that
funny we don't do that here you don't
have to be completely humorless but you
can be the grown-up in the room that
just sort of raises the bar don't wait
for the picked on person to have to say
it themselves I think those would be my
two very important all right Jim you
only get one wow those were really good
answers and actually I note that it's
all about people in the connection the
individual connections and I think when
i was a-sayin to a bolide I thought oh
that's exactly my answer so my answer is
the same as his I'd use two different
words and and that would be be a mentor
and be a role model right that and and
as Margaret said just reaching out to
somebody and talking to them and helping
and and that could be a student it could
be a colleague it could be a staff mit
could be lots of different people that
really personal touch really makes a
huge difference and and to be a role
model as well and
I think people as Margot said many
people here are senior people look to us
and how we behave and and I think that's
really important and there are lots of
different ways to role model and being a
mentor and being a role model is
absolutely no cost at all so I guess I
get to I'll take to wine would be become
this sounds like a really simple one but
you'd be surprised how often it's not
done use the spirit of inquiry that we
all have to challenge things in a nice
way so it's sort of like a question so
when somebody says I don't think Lucy's
qualified for that award spirit of
inquiry say well what makes you think
that or I don't think you know that our
body is a natural-born leader
well what's that mean anyway wait what
do you mean by that
one more question - not to say oh I you
know you're wrong or you know argue that
can come later right but just a question
in that learning moment to find out what
do they mean because we say things all
the time and we have no idea what they
mean and it's a learning moment for both
people cuz it could be that Lucy's not a
natural-born leader right I mean that
might well be by the way I don't think
there is anything as a natural-born me
but anyway okay so so the spirit of
inquiry is under rated and all of us are
researchers and innovators and we know
how to do that and it's just a question
it's the same kind of question you would
ask technically why do you think that
works or whatever so the spirit of
inquiry I think is super important and
the other thing I want to say is you
don't have to do this alone there a lot
of free resources and programs out there
there are some programs that cost a
little money but lots of ways to be
involved and see what has them CRA
W has them ACM W has programs there are
a lot of great programs out there to
give you research-based information so
that's kind of the last idea here is go
become informed this is not a heavy lift
for all of you smart people to go and
become informed about what social
science research says about
under-representation and then you're
going to be well equipped to use your
spirit of inquiry if you don't know what
unconscious bias means from a research
perspective
stereotype threat civility collective
intelligence intersectionality they're
like ten words you can find out very
easily and then you'll be very well
equipped to base your actions on
research so those are sort of our ideas
and I think we've got a few minutes for
questions Q&A if if people have any
questions from the audience I see
somebody with their hand up there
wait a minute someone's coming to you I
believe thank you all for your comments
um the one thing that I didn't hear
talked about was diversity inclusion
with respect to disability and I was
wondering if you would just take a
minute to address that and and how we
can we can aid in DNI for disability
well first of all right down the road at
u-dub there Richard Ladner do you want
to say more about that I will just say
one of the 7b PC activities is access
computing which really aimed
specifically at exactly that and as Lucy
mentioned that's been led for quite a
long time by by Richard Ladner amazing
guy at u-dub the only thing I'll say too
is we just discovered a gap in working
with Richard and a researcher Maya
Israel who looks a lot at universal
design and have discovered a pretty big
gap right now in terms of computing
curriculum and you know around Universal
Design for students with learning
disabilities so Richard works quite a
bit on physical disabilities and he's
starting to look at learning
disabilities and so that's kind of a
thing to think about like how could we
possibly create curriculum homework
assignments etc that enable students
with different learning disabilities to
succeed in our classrooms
you know I'll just add so CRA W has for
over 15 years offered a grad cohort for
women but a year ago we offered the
first URM D grad cohort which was a
co-ed grad court for underrepresented
minorities and people with disabilities
and we just set the date in the place
it's going to be March keep an eye out
March
20:19 will be the second of those you
RMD drag cohorts so now I may have
understood your question or comments a
little bit differently the way I
understood it in connection with the
diversity and its impact on innovation
is is bringing in people with different
abilities we know into the creative
process we ran into the idea generation
and the innovation process and I think
it's absolutely key for the same reasons
that we've talked about that what you
get at the end you know sort of born
accessible it's born with multiple
perspective it's born with the ability
to function and be useful for a broader
range of people in a broader range of
contexts you know and so I think it's a
thank you so much for grata anybody else
have a question
well alright so Thank You panelists
what's up let's thank our panelists for
yay all right thank you all
you